there is a major breaking story that has
taken place just hours ago special
prosecutor Robert Muller has spoken
publicly for the first time since the
release of the Moller report and he is
saying in no uncertain terms that he
cannot clear and has not cleared Donald
Trump of obstruction of justice and that
if he had been able to clear him on that
he would have and the report would have
reflected that now if you actually read
the Muller report you knew this already
Muller said publicly if we had
confidence the President did not commit
a crime we would have said so the reason
the report doesn't clear Trump is
because Muller cannot clear Trump from
criminality and Moeller again said that
even if the Justice Department won't
charge Trump there are other options
again a reference to impeachment a
little more context for what Robert
Muller said in the the first and
apparently only time we will hear from
him unless he ultimately does testify
when a subject of an investigation
obstructs that investigation or lies to
investigators it strikes at the core of
their government's effort to find the
truth and hold wrongdoers accountable
let me say a word about the report the
report has two parts addressing the two
main issues we were asked to investigate
the first volume of the report details
numerous efforts emanating from Russia
to influence the election this volume
includes a discussion of the Trump
campaigns response to this activity as
well as our conclusion that there was
insufficient evidence to charge a
broader conspiracy and in the second
volume the report describes the results
and analysis of our obstruction of
justice investigation involving the
president the order appointing me
special counsel authorized us to
investigate actions that could obstruct
the investigation and we conducted that
investigation and we kept the office of
the acting Attorney General
apprised of the progress of our work and
as set forth in the report after that
investigation if we had had confidence
that the president clearly did not
commit a crime we would have said so
Moeller has also announced that he's
retiring from the Justice Department
which formally ends his appointment as
special counsel so on one hand major
breaking news right the special counsel
saying I can't clear Trump it would be
very clear from my report if I was
clearing Trump you would know that by
looking at the report on the other hand
completely in line with what the Moller
report said and if you read the Moller
report instead of listening to William
bar instead of listening to Donald Trump
instead of listening to Fox News or
Hannity or the rest of them you would
know this already the bottom line is
that Donald Trump in all likelihood
committed crimes multiple counts of
obstruction of justice
Robert Moeller did not indict for
political reasons mainly the political
reason that the Justice Department has a
very dubious and and sort of unspoken
policy of simply not indicted sitting
presidents but does not indict sitting
presidents that's not a legal policy
it's a political policy Democrats should
immediately move forward with
impeachment debate on the floor of the
house it's time okay the momentum
arguably is here there's a public
statement from Robert Muller people are
going to prison Trump appears to have
obstructed justice let's move forward
Moeller is effectively sending a message
to Congress and telling them to decide
he says I didn't clear Trump you don't
need my testimony to move forward with
impeachment the report is riddled with
evidence of criminal obstruction of
justice
start the impeachment debate get things
going get testimony from witnesses
expose the content of the Moller report
to the American people because again I
said this recently on the show multiple
times 1% 2% 5% of the American public
I'm guessing has actually read through
the Moller report most people have not
most people are forming their opinion as
to what Robert Muller
based on William bars four-page letter
based on Donald Trump's worldwide
exoneration tour based on Fox News and
others continuing to insist insist no
collusion no obstruction that's not
what's in the report and if for no other
reason then the report says substantial
evidence of obstruction and the report
finds that on I believe it's eight of
the possible 14 counts of obstruction
all three legal requirements are met for
obstruction it's time to start the
impeachment debate what else are you
waiting for
whether it's Pelosi or it's whoever I
mean even to Republicans I would say it
it's very clear what needs to happen
it's not immediately the removal of the
president via an impeachment conviction
by the Senate it's start the debate on
the floor of the house about impeachment
we've heard from Muller he's confirmed
what's in the report it's time to do it
and by the way side note if you watched
the entire Moeller press conference a
statement he again talks about WikiLeaks
was the contact for Russia WikiLeaks was
a channel through which Russia was
sending and publishing information you
got to understand that that is something
that many on the right and left were
denying for the last two years once
again if you believe Moeller about no
conspiracy to collude then what is the
basis for not believing about WikiLeaks
or obstruction it's all in there it's
what the report says we've now heard it
from Muller it's time to act